l'ivresse de courir à nouveau avec ses
copains et ses copines privé de sport
une grande partie de l'année 500
écoliers tourangeaux ont rechaussé les
baskets aujourd'hui pour les fit days un
mini triathlon de passage à chinon
aurélie renouil était pas le temps car
il reste 1 km de course à pied pour ce
jeune garçon les sportifs aujourd'hui
ont entre 7 et 11 ans même programme
pour tout le monde tout commence par 20
m de natation dans une eau un peu
fraîche autre discipline le vélo sur un
petit kilomètre et le final 250 m de
course à pied avec des enfants à
l'arrivée combler mon arrivée je lui va
bien dans le triathlon parce qu'il me
dise in bas on peut te j'avais une
fatigue on est tous car il y avait les
ateliers et puis j'ai j'adorais en
faites pas
l'opération sillonnent les villes
françaises elle s'appelle fit days
l'objectif est simple lutter contre la
sédentarité des enfants et sont tous
très fiers d'être petit triathlète à la
fin de cette journée
il reçoit tous la médaille et c'était
une vraie incidence dans leur esprit et
repartent avec de la fierté
on a de très bons résultats des enfants
qui n'étaient pas du tout sportif qui du
fait qu'ils aient réussi ce petit
challenge est bien bien sûr après se met
au sport
être sportif c'est aussi comprendre son
corps gérer son effort travail et les
étirements josaphat à 10 ans passionné
de football il a appris à analyser sa
course son premier triathlon au vélo
c'est allé un peu trop vite au début du
coup j'ai dit si je vais trop vite je
parie va courir
du coup j'ai un peu ralenti et du coup
là après j ai réussi recourir elle est
belle cette médaille est heureux oui 500
petits élèves du chinonais ont goûté au
même plaisir celui de bouger après une
année contre 1 de côté sportif une
journée de triathlon et de cohésion
c'est ce qui vous fait verts feraient
même d'air chaud et puis il ya toujours
dans un paysage très agréable à chinon
et moi je suis content de les voir comme
ça aussi ravi aussi épanouie
a pas de compétition ni de podium mais
une médaille pour tout le monde et de
beaux souvenirs sportifs à partager